we are here with Sam Savion team a
result for you with the black pieces of
draw against Alex Slenderman take us
through the game uh well this is very
solid line in Catalan and he had an
interesting idea on Route 13 I believe
with A4
the idea is to play A5 and clamp down
the queen side
and kind of stops B6 in a way so I spent
some time here and I think I found a
very good way of playing against this
which is Rook FDA and now if he plays A5
I take on D4
uh Knight takes E4 or maybe Knight
clicks or C takes yeah if C takes 95 I
was thinking
stop the action of the bishop he has to
go E4 he creates his own weaknesses
right should be okay it should be okay
and if he takes away the Knight Bishop
C6 oh very nice
yeah and now it takes takes taking
advantage of the fact that white cannot
take with the Knight because of the pin
they take a bishop E3 Rook AC and this
opponent A5 looks very nice but I'm
threatening Knight D5 I think I think
that's fine absolutely uh and he played
the move Knight to B5 first yes and were
you aware that you guys are following
this game between nihal and petrozia I
wasn't I mean he was you think yeah
and you play The Rook uh A6 Knight to D6
yes were you at all worried that maybe
his two Bishops if he takes only eight
at any point will be conclusive at all I
never allowed him to you don't but God I
just immediately took on D6 yes and the
point is if he takes Bishop D6 I have
Knight D5
attacking C2 which forces Bishop to 65
66 and there's no more two Bishops yeah
and the other point is if he picks with
the Rook on D6 in the game I have Knight
D5
I think it's a very important move
because if C4 here instead of Bishop
yeah I was thinking either 93 or Knight
B6 I'm not sure which is better but
A5
does he take only two yeah it takes on
E2 cake Knight C3 Rook takes d8 Rook
takes d8 Knight C5
my lights are kind of awkward so
should I feel worried at this point but
I thought if it gets you have to
calculate and find a way to equalize
here some concrete way yeah yeah to to
make it but that's why I was also
considering that B6 after C4
18 C4
ah instead of root 6. No rookie six is
fine and C4 yes C4 Knight B6
um
about Bishop takes C6
this should take note A5
cap takes takes
I thought there should be quite
equalizers it looks like there should
have a lot of pressure right
uh there has to be a way to simplify
that yeah
at some point one pawns are going to
despite one of the students that has
space perfumes and then everything
Fizzles up absolutely and he played uh
five yeah e65 initially it looks like
one has a small plus because of this A5
but my pieces are on all an ideal square
root C which would be 596. it doesn't
allow him to do anything uh just one
quick question instead of F6 I go Bishop
C4
uh what does it say 94 Knight C5 and he
said he wants to take on C5 and play
King E1
yes I was interested in this position
because I can play bring my king to C7
play B6 was he still within his
theoretical knowledge
this was an idea where analyzing after
the game uh I'm guessing if I try to
bring my king he'll play H3 G4 and he'll
have Kevin play on the king side two
King is that one maybe H3 yeah yeah
probably there's just it's just a drone
position drawn but still maybe white has
some right right slight chance so it's
better just to trade the knights off
yeah absolutely well Sam how would you
assess your first couple of games and
how do you feel personally about torment
and about your shape that you are in uh
well I know Alex is a very strong player
and with black unless you take real
risks in the opening it's not easy to
beat him so I decided to play solid line
and you know I'm happy with it
absolutely and how about your form in
this tournament how do you feel after
the first couple of rounds I'm feeling
pretty good I'm seeing a lot of tactics
and calculating well so that's good
great to see that we'll see you in the
next couple of rounds thank you well
done Sam and there we have our results
uh